hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the community now it's
been a while since I played a Mimi's
stupid horror game and good to know this
is absolutely not that in fact this
might be the scariest horror game of
2016 in the little bit of time we have
in 2016 I think we may be facing the
most dire threat we've it the most dire
threat we've ever faced in our entire
life good to know that mirrors
functioning perfectly as a window into
the underworld and I'm approaching this
wall with utter care ok here we go oh
boy oh I've got oh oh what a lovely
pillow ah just shaped like a dead guy
that doesn't work at all hello ok
goodbye I thought I put I thought I'd
put the graphics on this to be
overwhelming oh boy
literally that was the graphics option
it was low medium high and then oh hello
every object in here I can I can tell
was custom made and blender just for
this occasion even the even the even the
illustrious mirrors here ok well
oh boy where am I I strike how's it
going good I'm good if you're good I'm
good okay okay I'm coming over
oh good I love company oh I'll be so not
alone anymore
Oh what is that we we but that I can't
even run said oh hello all right I can't
get near this door Oh company oh boy I
still can't get near the goddamn door do
I even want to answer that door is is he
coming ogre
I can't couldn't use a goddamn - oh here
we go hi oh god bud
oh god flashing hallway light Oh God
dark abyss oh god I'm gonna die alright
here we go then I'm trusting this I
don't know why I'm trusting this oh boy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
ow
[Music]
oh boy in fact I don't remember any of
this in anything I've ever done you
matter I'm Patrick
oh you're whispering such sweet nothings
into my ear oh oh no what is that hello
my friend
Oh Oh some by me okay I thought there
was oh hey oh my god that's
astonishingly creepy oh boy am i back in
my bed so I bet I'm not
oh god what is this is this supposed to
be tied to a table oh no no it's not oh
okay
all right then Wow that lens flare
though oh boy so so what what am I
supposed to interpret from this so these
knife gashes in the table here and is
that my blood let's move the TV just
simple you watch while I'm bored while
I'm being admitted you know there's
something relaxing I bet I can't open
any of these all right well that one's
got blood in it
[Music]
they're having a good time in here okay
all right you know maybe I don't need to
bother them maybe they're just having a
peaceful time by themselves and they
don't want to be bothered okay well I
guess that's all there is so me and Rob
here hello
freckles body dump Oh convenient body
dump
[Music]
[Applause]
wow this game is Game of the Year 10/10
11 out of 10 22 out of 10 oh boy oh boy
what's with the red ominous Gullu okay I
feel off I don't feel good about
pressing right of buttons oh it's an
elevator okay
DreamWorks oh you know research to find
out what the kids like in the next wreck
maybe oh boy oh boy
beside every that can't read back if
someone wanted to zoom in and read that
then maybe they'd have a better time
about that but I said okay I don't like
this not one bit the boss said
everything is fine but Dave and I can
see through [ __ ] whatever we're
creating it's not safe right oh ho ho
it's too dangerous to go through with it
considering we're in a [ __ ] sewer to
do this research with no security just
this whole thing is super Shady Dave
agrees with me whatever DreamWorks wants
us to create I don't want anything to do
with it I don't care if I lose my job I
just want out of this crazy [ __ ] David I
are gonna tell the boss we're quitting
tomorrow let's hope everything goes well
oh I imagine the dot everything goes
well if there's blood dripping from your
using vent oh boy oh boy fell fell fell
what kind of keypad is that doesn't even
need to put in anything okay long
hallway of blood how did I get here all
right I see how it is
laughter what Oh Alma brain what
happened I have no idea what's going on
oh no oh you finally it would you good
now let's try that again
why were you in that godforsaken sewer
sleep like both horror games I was just
trying to live gonna answer me why is it
because you were scared or do you just
don't know how to either way you've seen
too much oh you know about him
no don't you know his name is Mac that
can never be known to the public
oh we didn't for DreamWorks why well I
don't even know that even though I
wasn't if you were on foot boss I was
still just a puppet taking orders from
the higher-ups and their orders were to
mate that day motor
it was stupid I know and I wound up
having the old-world David Martin
DreamWorks told me if they ever told me
they were going to it I would have
killed him they told me they couldn't
risk David Martin breaking very MTA
because if they did read works would be
100% [ __ ] um if I were to it or not I
was told they wouldn't feel me either
way I was [ __ ] I had no choice
I remember the faithful day that a motor
broke out I was with a bunch of the
higher-ups from DreamWorks showing them
the progress the three of us had made
before I had fur killed him then well
something happened he oh if you started
riffing the guy's an F blood everywhere
they tried the door sealed shut they
tried to go though the air ducts she
just came after them and more of them
surprises I managed to escape no secret
passage that was built into the walls I
was the sole survivor and now I'm here
watching observing the ogre
wait what the oh [ __ ]
Oh way too long to make but it was
lovely nonetheless game of the year and
just in it the last two you know oh I
love for some reason I don't know why
but these Shrek meme horror games are
better than a lot of horror games that I
played Oh silly but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed that I got more horror games in
my list I just wanted to get through
this one because I don't know the
special soft spot in my heart for these
shrek horror games and I haven't played
a lot of them just I think the other one
was get out of my swamp I'll put a link
to that one in the description but thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you well [ __ ] you
buddy in the next video bye